[Music]
you have a newer documentary that's
about uh this is about metrosexuals it
just premiered at the tribeca film
festival we did a new movie with will
arnett and jason bateman two very funny
guys that looks at the magical world of
manscaping and it's called
manson okay yeah now is this a real
trend men when you say well no there's a
lot of there's a lot of people who are
like going down the manscaping route you
know they could try men she'll know that
but we found a product and you know
because we as we were making this film
you know when we made greatest movie
ever sold i brought you some mane and
tail and i thought you could you would
appreciate this product we found this is
a real product this is a real product
called fresh balls
and
so
the name pretty much says it all
what is it about tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
to barbara
walters or the french press
okay but what is the amazing thing about
freshly you know your band you don't
need to get me banned all right
in the film we go there and uh you know
they they do a focus group they have
guys come in and try the product and
what do you know i mean i don't want to
get i obviously would you like during
the focus group no no no no but just
what is this product supposed to achieve
well
one of the guys says after he put it on
he tells the guy who created he goes hey
listen it cured up my bat wings so
and for a batwing for those of you don't
know is when your scrotum sticks to your
thighs
so
this
you
i'm just saying
does a lot of sitting yeah golden sits a
lot this might be helpful
i'll cherish this
okay i don't want to ask anybody any
more questions about this product so
glad that you worked it into the
interview though
delighted
my mother will not be watching this show
uh